c'est la joie d'avoir une visite il
m'est difficile de vous gâcher flux en
temps celle de pierre tchernia qui va
nous présenter l'émission de oasis n'est
que nous allons regarder maintenant
émission intitulée l'ami public numéro
un
je pense avoir c'est vous qui en avez
choisi le type et vous me dire pourquoi
des biens raclée je pense qu'il est bon
de dire un mot sur cette émission
ce qui me paraît intéressant c'est
qu'elle nous permet de voir des extraits
de l'oeuvre de walt disney vous savez
qu'il y a souvent depuis de longues
années des tentatives d'amélioration des
rapports entre les entreprises
cinématographiques et direction de la
télévision et bien en voici une preuve
la maison walt disney qu'il n'a jamais
donné beaucoup beaucoup de documents à
la télévision va s'est amené nous
fournir l'occasion de faire quatre
émissions et j'ai eu le grand plaisir
d'en être chargé jeudi le grand plaisir
parce que je pense que tout le monde
aime beaucoup elles définissent en irak
il n'y a pas d'âge moi j'en suis un
exemple puis je suis très sentimental
c'est que mickey exactement mon âge
ah oui oui mickey a été inventé par walt
disney dans lesquelles elle est ouverte
aux jeunes il est charmant
donc nous allons avoir l'occasion au
cours de l'année de faire quatre grands
avantages d'émissions consacrées walt
disney et je vais je pense choisir
plusieurs thèmes y aura un thème que
nous verrons sans doute au début du mois
de février qui sera consacré à la
musique
un thème que nous verrons peut-être au
mois de mars ou d'avril qui sera
consacrée aux animaux et la première de
ces émissions est une émission qui va
vous permettre de faire un petit tour
dans l'univers de walt disney et dans la
carrière de walt disney
quelque chose les émissions ne porteront
pas toutes le même type non celle ci
s'appelle l'année public numéro 1 parce
qu'il fallait trouver un titre pour
définir walt disney et je pense que il
ya des gens qui ont des tests et qu'on
appelle l'ennemi public rayé roi lui
l'ennemi public numéro 1 car c'est un
homme qui a réussi à plaire au plus
grand nombre dans de très nombreux pays
pas c'est une chose qui est frappante
vous savez c'est que les personnages de
disney ont réussi à couvrir le monde
entier il ya des boîtes de camembert qui
s'appelle le camembert blanche neige par
exemple
oui mais ça se passe en france mais vous
avez des marques de sagement n'est pas
là dedans mais nous aurions gardé son
personnage je vous invitera dîner on
mangera l'a dit et je dois dire je pense
donc que la vie publique numéro un est
un titre qui convient à peu près à cette
sorte de panoramic dans l'oeuvre et la
carrière de walt disney que nous allons
faire maintenant avec le concours de nos
amis du télé cinéma car les bobines sont
là en bas télécinéma à vous de jouer